le prisme a ouvert sa saison culturelle
2020 2021
l'événement a lieu mercredi 7 octobre à
elancourt une soirée importante pour
l'établissement qui compte sur le
soutien du public c'est celle où à la
fois on montre tout le travail que l'on
a préparé dont on espère qu'il sera une
réussite pour cette nouvelle saison mais
c'est également celle où bien entendu
nous comptons sur la fidélité de nos
spectateurs et nous espérons faire un
maximum d'abonnement ce soir c'est une
programmation pluridisciplinaire qui
attend les spectateurs des thèmes autour
de l'humour du plaisir ou encore de la
réflexion toujours de l'écriture et de
la création contemporaine avec le cas
liban théâtre création chorégraphique la
compagnie mais mévente jo qui viendra
également créé ici cette saison un
spectacle qui s'appelle dimanche
éperdument programmateur et artistes
étaient au rendez vous pour présenter la
saison à venir
ils nous parlent de leur spectacle
chacun dans un style différent
vraiment on demande en direct aux gens
de nous donner des thèmes donc ça peut
arriver que ce soit le coc vide ou
d'autres choses ou leur vie privée par
exemple dans la foi c'est un mec qui
avait il perdait ses cheveux
donc il voulait qu'on parle de sa perte
de cheveux et on on a parlé de ça juste
vous demander pour faire connaissance
regardez la personne qui est assis à
votre droite regardez la personne qui a
certes droite regardez bien cette
personne
oh je vous demandais en toute
bienveillance et en toute honnêteté
évidemment de me donner une note de 1 à
10 sur la physique de sur le physique de
cette personne
moi je fais un théâtre qui est assez
particulier qui mélange habituellement
du théâtre récit de la danse hip hop de
l'image animée et de la musique live
la saison du prisme débutera avec un
spectacle de marc lavoine le samedi 9
janvier 2021
[Musique]